LATE START AND WELCOME TO THE
MAY FIRST THE MAY DATE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HAPPY
MADE A TO ALL THE WORKERS IN THE
BUILDING AND BEYOND -- WE HAVE A
UNDRED AND EIGHTY TWO BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING I'D LIKE
TO THINK.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FREEDMAN FOR
FILLING IN FOR I'D MISS EGGMAN
THIS MORNING AND MISTER -- JONES
SAWYER WILL FILL IN FOR DOCTOR
QUIRK THIS MORNING.
I NOTICED THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WITH THAT WE WILL START
AS A SUB COMMITTEE AND A
CRISTINA GARCIA IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE UP FIRST.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON SEVEN
FIFTY SIX GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS -- THIS BILL HAS
GONE THROUGH SOME CHANGES AN AD
AIDS THE WATER BOARD AND IT'S
THE FAITH INVESTIGATIVE PROCESS
TO GATHER INFORMATION ABOUT THE
SEVERITY OF P. FOSS
CONTAMINATING OUR WATER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOIL
I'M ABLE.
DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW ME
ASSURE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO NOT THE FILE AT
THIS TIME.
THANK YOU.
SEE KNOW WHAT QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE.
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
WHEN YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
WE HAVE HARM WILL TAKE THAT UP.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA MISS
BURNER WHO ARE BAATH.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING ON AB SIXTY NO SEVEN
IT DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ONCE WE GET A
QUORUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BUT I'M SURE
MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN WILL
REQUIRE CITIES AND COUNTIES TO
ISSUE A NOTICE TO THE BUSINESS
WITH INFORMATION ABOUT THE
GENDER TAX REPEAL ACT.
AT THE TIME THE BUSINESS
RECEIVES ITS BUSINESS LICENSE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE GENDER TAX
REPEAL ACT PROHIBITS BUSINESSES
FROM CHARGING DIFFERENT PRICES.
FOR SERVICES BASED ON GENDER.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT BUSINESSES ARE AWARE
OF THE REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
ACT.
THE FISCAL ANNOUNCES ESTIMATES
MINOR REIMBURSABLE COST TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES TO ISSUE THE
NOTICES WHICH CAN BE OFFSET BY
INCREASED BUSINESS LICENSES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THEIR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEAH SO REFORM WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CAL CHAMBER SUPPORTS AB SIXTEEN
OH SEVEN BECAUSE IT WILL PROVIDE
NOTICED ALL IMPACTED BUSINESSES
OF THE GENDER TAX REPEAL ACT.
AT THE OUTSET OF THEIR BUSINESS
WHICH WILL ALLOW BETTER
BUSINESSES TO BETTER COMPLY --
AND PREVENT FAILED FALLING
VICTIM TO FRIVOLOUS ACOSTA
LITIGATION FOR THESE REASONS
WEAKER CHAPLAIN.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I SEEN IT -- QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ONCE YOU'VE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM THANK YOU
WILL TAKE THAT UP [inaudible]
NEXT MISS [inaudible]
RAY YES.
REYES I DON'T HAVE ANY BILLS FOR
YEAR THAT AREN'T ON SUSPENSE OR
ONE SEVENTY NINE IT'S NOT FULL
OF THAT'S ON CONSENT DO YOU WANT
TO PULL THAT OFF CONSENT.
NO.
DIDN'T THINK YOU WOULD THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I DON'T KNOW WHO
SIGNED IN FIRST BETWEEN --
MISTER LOW MISTER GLORIA SEE
GUYS CAN FLIP A COIN AND MR LOW.
MR LET YOU BE PRESENT IN AB.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WHEN.
TAKE IT OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MANAGER MEMBERS THIS IS SYMBOL
EIGHT EIGHT PART OF NON FROM A
LOGICAL TREATMENTS FOR PAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
GOOD MORNING TIM VALDERRAMA WITH
THE WHITEMAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF
CAL CAIRO WERE SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE WE'RE JOINED BY DOCTOR
WILLIAMS SHE'S GOING TO GIVE A
BRIEF COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
DOCTOR INJURE WILLIAMS A DOCTOR
OF CHIROPRACTIC A MEMBER OF
CALIFORNIA CHIROPRACTIC
ASSOCIATION SPONSORING AB.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT I CURRENTLY
WORK AT A LARGE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY PRACTICE -- AT A
TECH COMPANY SERVING -- FIVE
THOUSAND PATIENTS IN ELK GROVE --
IN OUR CLINIC WE ARE MEDICAL
DOCTORS NURSES ACUPUNCTURISTS
PHYSICAL THERAPIST MASSAGE
THERAPIST DENNIS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND CHIROPRACTIC CARE FOR
PATIENTS.
THE MIS USE OF OPIOIDS INCLUDING
PRESCRIPTION PAIN MEDICA
RELIEVERS HAND SYNTHETIC OPIOIDS
IS A NATIONAL EPIDEMIC.
THAT AFFECTS OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
AS WELL AS OUR SOCIAL ECONOMIC
WELFARE.
IT'S CLEAR THAT A CHANGES NEED
IN THE WAY WE TREAT PAIN
MANAGEMENT AND A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY APPROACH INVOLVING
NON FROM A LOGICAL TREATMENTS
CAN BE A SOLUTION.
AS NOTED BY A STUDY DONE IN --
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
TREATMENTS SUCH AS ACUPUNCTURE
CHIROPRACTIC CARE THE MISSION TO
BE MORE EFFECTIVE MORE COST
EFFECTIVE THAN OPIOID
PRESCRIPTIONS.
ON BEHALF OF CAL CAIRO ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU FOR
TAP [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
WAITING FOR OPPOSITION.
ARE YOU SMART ALL DRESSED I
SPEAKER TALUKA REPRESENTING THE
INDEPENDENT PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
I'VE BEEN AUTUMN OR ON BEHALF OF
THE OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible] FOR MORE.
IF YOU HOLD FOR JUST ONE MAN I
WANT ESTABLISH A QUORUM IF
POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BRO CALDERON.
CARRILLO.
CHAU.
DEEP [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
PHONE [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
NORTH.
JUNE FIRST FOR COURT QUIRK
PRESENT AND READY TO VOTE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WITH THEIR
OPPOSING ARGUMENT THINGS GET
MORNING TURN MEMBERS MAKING ALL
RIGHT ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
CONTINUING CONCERN OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S BEEN THE
INCREASING COST OF HEALTHCARE IN
THE STATE AND THIS BILL WILL
SERVE TO FURTHER EXACERBATE THAT
PROBLEM BY INCREASING
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
PHYSICIANS AND MANDATING
ADDITIONAL COSTS TO CONSUMERS.
THERE UNNECESSARY REFERRALS FOR
SERVICES WHICH ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO BE COVERED BY HEALTH PLANS
RESULTING IN LARGE OUT OF POCKET
COSTS.
THE UNNECESSARY CONVERSATION
ABOUT NON PHARMACOLOGICAL
OPTIONS MANDATED IN THE INFORMED
CONSENT TAKES AWAY FROM THE
MEANINGFUL CONVERSATIONS THAT
CAN BE HAD.
IN ALREADY SHORT APPOINTMENT
TIMES THE MANDATED REFERRAL IF
APPROPRIATE STILL LEAVES
PATIENTS HOLDING THE BILL FOR
THESE SERVICES AS THEY'RE TOLD
THEY'RE RECEIVING A REFERRAL.
BUT THIS ISN'T A REALITY IN
MEDICINE OR REFERRAL IS THE
THING IT'S OFTEN A PHYSICAL
DOCUMENT TELLING PATIENTS TO SEE
A SPECIFIC PROVIDER FOR SERVICE
THAT WILL OFTEN BE COVERED
BECAUSE OF THAT POSITION
REFERRAL.
THE PROPONENTS IMAGINE THE
REFERRAL IN THIS BILL TO BE AKIN
TO A SUGGESTION OR
RECOMMENDATION SUCH AS LIKE A
HOUSE PAINTER INFORMAL CASUAL
AND NON COMMITTAL.
THESE NON PHARMACOLOGICAL
SERVICES ARE LARGELY LARGELY
PAID FOR OUT OF POCKET AND
PROVIDING A REFERRAL WILL GIVE A
FALSE SENSE TO THE PATIENT THAT
THEY'LL BE RECEIVING SOME SORT
OF COVER BENEFIT.
BECAUSE THEIR DOCTOR REFERRED
THEM FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK
FOR YOU KNOW VOTE ON AB.
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
JERRY HEX REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AND ALSO AT THE
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGIST IS RICK -- NINE
LIKE IN MY COMMENTS ON THE
POLICY TO THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE ALSO I TALKED
WITH -- OUR ATTORNEYS LAST NIGHT
WE ALSO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
LIABILITY.
SO THERE MAY NOT BE COSTS -- TO
THE STATE -- IN THE ANALYSIS BUT
WE DO BELIEVE THEY'LL BE COSTS
FOR PROVIDERS ALSO FOR PATIENTS
AS WAS MENTIONED MANY OF THESE
SERVICES ARE NOT COVERED UNDER
INSURANCE OR MEDIC CAL -- BUT
ALSO.
THE CONSENSUS YOU KNOW WE DON'T
LIVE IN AN ERA ANYMORE WHERE
PEOPLE ARE JUST -- ADDING THINGS
TO MEDICAL TIRED EVERYTHING'S
ELECTRONIC AT THIS POINT AND SO
ADDING THINGS -- WE ALREADY DO
INFORMED CONSENT FOR SURGICAL
PROCEDURES FOR OTHER THINGS BY
ADDING THINGS JUST YOU KNOW AS
AN ITEM.
ALSO MAKES US TO HAVE TO CHANGE
HOW THE ELECTRONIC MEDICAL
RECORDS MEDICAL RECORDS ARE DONE
THAT'S VERY COSTLY TO PROVIDERS
POTENTIALLY NOT EVEN POSSIBLE --
AND THEN IN ADDITION IF THERE'S
A MANDATE FOR REFERRALS OR IN
EVEN INFORMATION TO BE PROVIDED --
SOMETIMES THAT'S OUTSIDE OF WHAT
IS THE STANDARD OF CARE SO
YOU'RE ASKING PHYSICIANS TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT SERVICES.
THAT MIGHT NOT BE A RECOMMENDED
SERVICE BUT ALSO SOMETHING
THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THEIR MEDICAL
HOME AND SOMETHING THAT THEY MAY
NOT EVEN KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
SOME PHYSICIANS DON'T INHERENTLY
KNOW.
ABOUT CHIROPRACTORS SERVICES OR
ACUPUNCTURE AND WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S BEST YOU ALSO DO NOT NEED
A REFERRAL FOR MOST OF THESE FOR
PHYSICAL THERAPY WHICH IS WITHIN
THE MEDICAL HOME AND MOST OF
THOSE.
FOLKS ARE WORKING -- WITHIN A
MEDICAL GROUP THOSE REFERRALS
THAT -- ARE APPROPRIATE AND ARE
ALREADY DONE BUT YOU DON'T NEED
A REFERRAL TO GO TO A
CHIROPRACTOR AND YOU DON'T NEED
A REFERRAL TO GO TO ACUPUNCTURE.
SO PUTTING A MANDATE IN LAW FOR
PHYSICIANS TO HAVE TO REFER OR
EVEN GIVE INFORMATION.
IS INAPPROPRIATE AND POTENTIALLY
WE'RE PUTTING SOMETHING INTO A
MAN ICAL RECORD THAT COULD BE --
A LIABILITY ISSUE TO THAT
POSITION LATER ON SO FOR THESE
REASONS FOR OPPOSING TODAY THANK
YOU.
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
[inaudible]
FILE.
DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS.
I'M JUST GONNA NOTE MR LOW -- I
DIDN'T FIND THIS TO BE AT A COST
TO THE STATE AND SO FOR THAT
REASON IN THIS FISCAL COMMUNITY
WE DID HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION -- I AM VOTING
FOR IT TODAY I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AND I KNOW THAT THERE
MIGHT BE A COUPLE -- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHO ALSO HAVE QUESTIONS
AND PERHAPS BEFORE YOU TAKE IT
TO THE FLOOR YOU MAY -- WANT TO
AS HAVE THEM SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS SO BUT FOR TODAY -- ON
THE FISCAL QUESTION -- WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION NOW THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WILL MOVE THE BILL.
REALLY MISS DOCTOR QUIRK -- MR
TO GET FULL SECOND.
AND THAT WILL GET.
OUT ON IN A ROLL CALL.
I'M SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
AND HAPPY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS I SHOULD THIS
MOVE.
FOR THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
WITH MR BRO -- MR FUNG AND MS
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU MR Là.
BEFORE WE GO ON TO THE OTHERS --
I'D ENTERTAIN A MESSAGE AT
MESSAGE YEAH.
OF A MOTION ON AB SIXTEEN OH
SEVEN MISS BURNER **** ABOUT
THAT SAID YOU PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY MISTER
BIGELOW AND THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON AB SEVEN FIFTY SIX
MISS GARCIA.
I MET A MOTION BY MS CARILLO A
SECOND BY MISTER JONES SAWYER --
WE'RE GONNA WAIT ON A COUPLE OF
MORE MEMBERS THAT WILL BE PLACED
ON CALL.
WE'RE ALL CAUGHT UP.
ALL RIGHT -- MISTER GLORIA.
AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT ENJOY THE
PAST RECOMMENDATION.
OF THE BILL.
THE MOTION BY MISS KOREA IN A
SECOND BY MISTER JONES SAWYER.
I'D JUST LIKE TO ASK YOU HAVE A
GREAT TO A SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
YES I'LL ALSO BE QUICK JENNIFER
FANG ON BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR
AMERICAN WILD HORSE CAMPAIGN AND
ALSO SAN DIEGO HUMANE SOCIETY IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
A GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR KERN
CAROLING OVER THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL FOR ASSOCIATION ALSO
SUPPORT TODAY.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE [inaudible]
NO FILE.
WHICH I CLOSE SEC FAST DRIVER
THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING SET FOR
MISTER DEEP HIS BODY IN HI.
AT THIS POINT -- WE WILL TAKE
THAT AB SEVEN FIFTY SIX OFF CALL
IN THAT GETS OUT WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
MISTER GORE YOU HAVE A SECOND
TELL ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AB.
ELEVEN FIFTY YES IT IS -- AB
ELEVEN FIFTY MADAM CHAIR
REQUIRES KIDS FOR BOTH THE SAN
DIEGO OF COURSE NOT QUIT MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS --
GOVERNING BOARDS TO COLLECT AT
LEAST A HUNDRED SIGNATURES IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR CANDIDACY IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT.
THIS BILL WOULD IMPOSE MINOR
CASA THE STATE SHOULD WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISCREANT A SECOND BY
MISS FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
PORT.
MANAGER MEMBERS BRIAN HOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE PROP CLOSE A
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT MOST QUALIFIED
AND COMMITTED CANDIDATES TO RUN
FOR THESE OFFICES -- WE ARE WE
ARE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CNN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO
FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WHICH ARE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
THAT GETS OUT AND WE WILL CALL
WITH MR DF NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU.
THEY WERE LITTLE LOW ON AUTHORS
WE WILL -- GO TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT HAVE BILLS TO
PRESENT.
PETRIE-NORRIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
START [inaudible]
THE NEXT -- NOTE NO SUSPENSE
WELLS AB TWELVE SIXTY FOUR
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION --
WHEN YOU WOULD LIKE TO BEGAN?
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
AM HERE TODAY DAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR THIS MOTEL I
MISS FRIEDMAN A SECOND BY MISTER
JONES SAWYER THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND I'VE GOT A AS SUPPORTER
AND SPONSOR HERE TO TESTIFY.
HI THANK YOU MIKE GIPSON WITH --
POT A PLAN HERE HEAVILY TO
CALIFORNIA -- BASICALLY WE ALL
KNOW THAT PROVIDED HEALTH IS
GOOD FOR PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES
SO YOU SEE THAT THIS BILL COULD
EVEN HAVE COST SAVINGS FOR THE
STATE.
ARE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
APARTMENT A FINANCE NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER
THAT GETS OUT IN ANY ROLL CALL
WITH MR BROWN MR FUNG NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
THANK.
I MISSED OUR K. HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT.
ALRIGHT.
YOUR NEXT STEP THEN.
YOU WILL PRESENT ON AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION BY MS FREEMAN A
SECOND BY MISTER JONES SAWYER
THANK YOU FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE IT
WOULD PROHIBIT REAR RESTING
INCARCERATING INDIVIDUAL FOR
INABILITY TO PAY.
CURRENTLY IT WE PAY WE SPEND IS
SO FOUR THOUSAND FOUR AND THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS INCARCERATE THESE
PEOPLE INSTEAD OF JUST ALLOWING
THEM TO SERVE PROBATION WHEN
THEY'VE DONE NOTHING.
BUT NOT BE ABLE TO PAY THEIR
COMPLY WITH ALL THE OTHER TERMS
OF THEIR PROBATION SO THIS BILL
WOULD CHANGE THAT ENSURE THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO CAN'T PAY
REMAIN ON PROBATION INSTEAD OF
INCARCERATED.
WITH THAT.
THE GIVE YOU LIZZY BUCKLEY FROM
THE ACLU.
GOOD MORNING.
IS A GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
LISTED EVEN WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE THE BILL
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT PEOPLE THAT
PROBATION CANNOT BE REVOKED
SIMPLY BECAUSE A PERSON IS TOO
POOR TO PAY THEIR FINES AND FEES.
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED STATES
PRINT PARTS OF ALREADY FOUND
THAT DOING SO WOULD VIOLATE
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TO DUE PROCESS
AND EQUAL PROTECTION.
THIS BILL CODIFIES THAT CASE LAW
TO CLARIFY THE COURTS CANNOT
REVOKE SOUNDS PROBATION SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO POOR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
ANY QUESTIONS.
CHECK IT OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AT THIS POINT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE -- EMOTIONAL CONSENT
CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS GRAHAM
AND A SECOND BY MISTER JONES
SAWYER MA'AM SURGERY WE PLEASE
READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB 254-091-4031 791-852-7230
329-551-6590 359-664-04650 THREE
SIX SEVENTY TWO SEVEN OH THREE
EIGHT OO TO EIGHT OH SIX EIGHT
OR 981-581-9888. SEVENTY FOUR
NINE FORTY THREE NINETY TWO FOR
THE
TEN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN TEN
THIRTY TO ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN
ELEVEN FIFTY TO TWELVE TWENTY
THREE THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX FOURTEEN OH
FOUR FOURTEEN FIFTY TO FOURTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE FIFTEEN THIRTY TO FIFTEEN
FIFTY FOUR FIFTEEN NINETY ONE
SIXTEEN SIXTY TWO SIXTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
SIXTY CHECK.
IT OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
AT THIS POINT -- MANSER CHE WE
PLEASE READ THE BILLS THAT WILL
BE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
AB 348-183-1408.
ONE SIXTY THREE
ONE SEVENTY FOUR ONE SEVENTY SIX
ONE EIGHTY ONE NINETY SIX TO
ELEVEN TO TWENTY ONE TO THIRTY
TWO TO FORTY THREE TO FIFTY
EIGHT TO EIGHTY SIX THREE OH ONE
THREE OH TWO THREE OH THREE
THREE TEN THREE FOURTEEN THREE
SIXTY THREE TWENTY NINE THREE
FIFTY SEVEN THREE FIFTY EIGHT
THREE SIXTY NINE THREE SEVENTY
TWO THREE SEVENTY.
635-675-76630.
761-666-6216 967-197-7677
779-792-8298 368-398-40260
1-688-789-1890.
EIGHT NINE THIRTY ONE NINE
EIGHTY A CHANNEL TO CHANNEL.
SEVENTEEN TWELVE TO NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT TO SIXTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT ELEVEN FIFTY SEVEN ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
TWELVE TWELVE TWELVE SIXTEEN
TWELVE NINETEEN TWELVE FOR
TWELVE SIXTY TWO A 931-303-1307.
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
FOURTEEN FORTY NINE FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR FIFTEEN
HUNDRED FIFTEEN OH THREE FIFTEEN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWENTY FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO
FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN
FO.
BILLS HAVE HAD BEEN DEEMS TO
COST MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS HAVE BEEN MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE -- AND THE
AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED PRESENTATION --
WE WILL ALLOW AT THE END OF THE
MEDIAN AN OPPORTUNITY IF YOU'RE
HERE TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION FROM ONE OF THOSE
BILLS -- YOU MAY DO SO THAT IS
NOT NECESSARY I HAD BUT BUT YOU
ARE FREE TO DO THAT AT THE END
OF THE HEARING -- IF NOT YOU MAY
SEE ASK HOW THAT BILL HAS BEEN
DISPENSED OF ON ME THE SIXTEENTH.
WITH THAT I DO WANT AN OUNCE
THAT AB THREE NINETY ONE BY MR
VOEPEL WAS AN AUTHOR PULL SO WE
WILL NOT BE HEARING THAT TODAY --
WE WILL GO BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH -- BILLS TO PRESENT
MISTER JONES SAWYER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL.
MISTER JONES SAWYER AYE IS AB
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN AND ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE
BILL THE MOTION BY MISS CARILLO.
A SECOND BY.
MISTER CHAO.
TARA OKAY THANK YOU.
AB I'M HERE TO THAT AB. SIXTEEN
EIGHTEEN A BILL TO REPEAL THE
CORSET ALREADY TO SPEND DRIVERS
LICENSES FOR PRIVILEGES FOR
VANDALISM IN RECENT -- PREVIOUS
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN MOVING TOWARDS
ANY TO PRACTICES SPENDING
DRIVING PRIVILEGES FOR
INFRACTIONS UNRELATED TO DRIVING
SUCH AS UNPAID FINES AND TRUANCY --
REPEALING THE COURTS
AUTHORIZATION TO SUSPEND DRIVING
PRIVILEGES FOR VANDALISM DOES
NOT HAVE ANY DIRECT COSTS TO THE
STATE MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE BOAT WITH ME TODAY FOR
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS MY A
GROUP THE ACLU.
YOUR SUPPORT.
MY ANGER MAY CHAU CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES THE CONSULTANT
PEOPLE CAN'T GET TO WORK SCHOOL
OR TAKE THE KIDS TO THE DOCTOR.
THANK YOU.
SPEARS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
NO FILE.
WONDERFUL.
WHICH I CLOSE THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THAT GETS OUT
AND IT BE ROLL CALL THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER BANK -- MR
GABRIEL WALKED IN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL.
MR GABRIEL YOU HAVE AB SIX
TWENTY FOUR IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
MOVE THE BILL WITH A MOTION BY
MS CARILLO IN A SECOND BY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN.
ABOUT A THIRD MEMBERS I PLEASE
TODAY PERCENT EIGHTY SIX TWO
FOUR WHICH WOULD REQUIRE SCHOOLS
THAT USED ISSUE STUDENT ID CARDS
TO INCLUDE PHONE NUMBERS FOR
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH HOT LINES ON
THE ID THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
IS TO ENSURE THE YOUNG PEOPLE
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS TIMELY AND
ACCURATE INFORMATION THAT MAY BE
A CENTRAL TO THEIR PHYSICAL OR
MENTAL WELL BEING.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YOUR BETWEEN.
THIS IS CHRISTINE AS MATH OF
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND
THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE IN A IN
SUPPORT.
GREAT SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPORT RANCHO WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION ABOUT.
I GUESS THAT WOULD BE ROLL CALL
WITH MR YEP NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
[inaudible]
MR CHOW.
MR CHOW HAS AB THREE EIGHTY FOUR
UP IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS FREEMAN.
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB THREE
D. FOR WHAT EMPLOYMENT
REASONABLE REGULATIONS FOR THE
USE OF DIGITAL HEALTH FEEDBACK
SYSTEMS.
INCLUDING ITEMS AS AS DIGITAL
PILLS WHICH ARE PHARMACEUTICALS
COMBINED WITH IN JUST DOUBLE
MICROCHIP SENSORS THAT CAN
RECORD INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PERSON TAKING THEM THE BILL WILL
HAVE MINOR PHYSICAL COST TO
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
[inaudible]
AT THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
IN A FINANCE.
NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
AS FOR ADULTS.
YOU GET IT.
THE ROLL CALL -- MR B. I SEE
YOU'RE HERE BUT ARE YOU TO
MISTER BONTA HE COULD GO NEXT IF
THAT'S OKAY I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
USUALLY WE MISTER BONTA YOU HAVE
THAT.
AB SEVENTY TEEN FORTY EIGHT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED.
WE MOTION BY MISTER CARILLO
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW THANK
YOU THE BILL HAS MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
VERY SHORT ON THE ON FISCAL.
FROM -- TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION
LOCAL FIVE FIVE SIX OFFICE AND
ITS FLIGHT ATTENDANTS -- DUE TO
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF OUR WORK --
FLIGHT ATTENDANTS WORK AT THREE
TO FOUR DAY -- SHIFTS PER WEEK --
THE THRESHOLD -- FOR TWELVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOURS -- WERE.
CAN TO TO LOWER THAT TO FIVE OH
FOUR TO MEET THE F. M. LA --
FEDERAL STANDARD.
AND WE URGE HEY I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
AND I AM ALSO PLANS NEVER STOP
WITH YOUR LINES AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE ALL OF YOU TO VOTE FOR
AND A BUT FOR THIS BECAUSE WE
AND AS MATT STATED HAVE THAT
TECHNICAL CORRECTION WILL AFFORD
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS THE ABILITY.
TO EXTEND THEIR LEAVES OF
ABSENCE AND IN ESPECIALLY IN
REGARDS TO INSURANCE BENEFITS SO
WE WOULD APPRECIATE YOU ALL --
IN A VOTE FOR THIS MAN AT BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS I MR BONTA
HAPPY MADE A THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL.
THE QUEUE MANAGER [inaudible]
MS RUBIO.
MS RUBIO YOU HAS YOU HAVE AB TEN
SEVENTY THREE TO ENJOY THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE
MORNING TURN MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SEVENTY THREE WHICH AUTHORIZES
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ENTER.
ISRAEL MOVES THE BILL AND THEN
AGREEMENT -- WITH IMMIGRATION
CUSTOM INFORMS MEANT TO LIMIT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES AT THE
VICTIM SERVICE LOCATIONS
MENTIONED IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OCTOBER TWENTY JONES
SAWYER.
ON IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT AND
SINCE WE'RE OPERATING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO INTERNET
INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH ICE BASED
ON MY TO POLICIES.
THAT WE ALREADY SEVEN PLATES ARE
WE ARE ANTICIPATING MINOR
OBSERVABLE CASA NIGHT -- ASK FOR
YOUR BILL THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEARS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTION WHICH I CLOSE
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THAT GUESTS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT VOTING EXCEPT FOR MISTER DE
UP WHO VOTES HIGH.
THANK YOU MISTER VIA.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE DOWN TO THAT
POINT WHERE THE WE NEED SOME
AUTHORS.
MR MCCARTY SAVES THE DAY.
MR MCCARTY YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING ON AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MOVE A MOTION BY
MISS KOREA SECOND BY MISTER
JONES SAWYER YES THIS IS THE
DON'T HAVE ANY PAPER ANYTHING
WHICH IS THE COLLEGE.
ADMISSIONS REFORM [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
OKAY.
YES I SHOULD WALK UP.
NO RHONDA OKAY FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES BROWN'S YES THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WOULD PROTECT
STUDENTS IN THE PORT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE SECTOR.
BY BETTER REGULATING THOSE WHO
GET KICKBACKS INCENTIVES TO PUT
PEOPLE IN THE SEATS AS OPPOSED
FOR LOOKING OUT FOR THEIR BEST
INTEREST FOR NOT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT BUDDY THANK YOU MISTER
MCCARTY.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR MR OBERNOLTE
AND MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE OR
MR LEVINE WE ARE DOWN TO TWO
AUTHORS.
SINCE WE HAVE NEITHER IF YOU ARE
IN THE AUDIENCE AND YOU WANTED
TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ONE OF THE BILLS
THAT WAS MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE.
YOU MAY GO TO THE I HAD A
MICROPHONE AND DO THAT NOW.
SEEING NONE OF WE HAVE TO BILLS
MR LEVINE AND MISTER OBERNOLTE I
NEED THOSE AUTHORS TO COME DOWN
OR A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESENT ON THEIR BEHALF
[inaudible]
RIGHT NOW -- YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE THE AUTHORS --
A FEW MINUTES UNLESS WE HEAR
OTHERWISE --
MR MAIENSCHEIN HAS
AGREED TO GIVE AT TO TO SPEAK ON
MISTER OVER NO TO THESE BILL --
LOOK AT THAT HE WILL DO BOTH.
WE'LL START WITH MR OBERNOLTE IS
BILL -- MR OBERNOLTE HAS AB
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW.
AND A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO --
I'M SORRY SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
NOT THIRTEEN NINETY SIX AGAIN.
MR OBERNOLTE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW IN
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- AB --
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS A GOOD
BILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY SPEAKERS
OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO FILE.
YES YES NO THANK YOU.
AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
I SEEN MR LEVINE JUST WALKED IN
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE MISTER
LEVINE'S -- BILL AT THE LAST
BILL -- OF THE DAY AB SIX SIXTY
EIGHT ENJOY THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MS CARILLO WE HAVE.
EIGHTY SECOND BY.
BY MR CHOW.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHURN NUMBER SIX SIXTY WILL
CREATE COOL ROOFS FOR CALIFORNIA
WILL DOUBLE THE REFLECTIVE
STANDARD IT WILL BE MORE
EFFICIENT TO LET -- MORE --
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY AND
THEY'LL HELP REDUCE HEAT ISLANDS
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESPECT LAST
AND I VOTE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO.
FIVE WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION.
ACTUALLY MISS KOREA CARILLO
MOVED AT MR CHOW SECONDED IT SO.
YOUR BILL HAS BEEN MOVED FOUR
TIMES AND SECONDED A FEW MORE AS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK
THAT WAS WORTH -- POSSIBLY
SPEEDING HERE FROM FROM HOME
THIS MORNING TO GET HERE AT AND
A TIMELY MANNER FOR YOU SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU TAKE IT OUT ON THE
ROAD CALL WITH MR YEP NOT VOTING
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE THAT'S
THE LAST BILL THAT CONCLUDES.
OUR APPROPRIATIONS HEARING TODAY
WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN. FOR
THREE MINUTES OF MR WILL L. T.
TO MAKE IT OUT OF COMMITTEE IF
NOT.
HE'LL JUST NOT HAVE BEEN PRESENT